I promise you it's gonna be in ten
minutes
but first of all join me in thanking the
incredible staff of the NHS they have
done it an amazing job I only get to see
new faces but I know how hard how
stressful how difficult times are for
all of you right now so behalf of the
Ramseys please keep it the good work and
God bless and thank you now when I said
ten minutes last we go around because
Megan pan down fast enough I was overrun
by 90 seconds so mad when I say pan down
pan down okay I need to look my
sous-chef he's running around somewhere
he was spotted hunt down pan down pat
down right only months ago but she's
still a baby and missus sophisticated
herself who's got the lighting to make
up for all of us not back again Holly
[Laughter]
first of all hello okay
yeah song come on now on the pretty one
through the angry voice at the timer I'm
gonna get scrutinized if I'm running
littering second zone this time my pen
down pat down we've got some amazing ok
ground beef you don't got beef turkeys
good chickens look lamb is give anything
ground meat you've done it's a bass
straightforward stir-fried rice that's a
literary steamed rice from last night's
curry red onion chilies red pepper
yellow pepper don't get out of about the
color
there's no big difference than flavor
okay so the Matt time they sit in the
Sun mushroom bok choy next to that a
little bit of munch to make pen down
some lifting greens up please it looks
like I won't really study twice come on
monsters and then some ginger and some
garlic
okay a little bit of coriander soy sauce
pan down me and a little bit of olive
oil okay
and a touch of fish sauce so this is
optional okay if your neck I will show
you to do it with an egg okay now first
of all here we go right yes up get it
nice and hot okay
now my community partners slow down
don't slow down too much but it's not
going to get the beef okay
crispy get a pan nice and hot okay put
the beef and sort of almost break it up
into little bits just open up a little
bit almost like the spring 200 plates
okay that's gonna get it
separating the pan now from there once
you've opened up that beef okay almost
in the also little granules just
literally open it up that way when we
come to fry it cannot make pan up pan up
mate it's really we're going to get it
really nice and crispy now the secret
here is get some color on it okay
so give that pan super hot now from
there just like never and sort of
address sort of let it almost break up
into little modules just like that from
there a little bit of seasoning okay
such a salt dough about the chain will
go down in a minute and then a touch of
war now the crazy oil literally half a
teaspoon of all in there it's a nonstick
pan and then another dot
the deep around okay sort of spread it
around
don't just rub in the middle which will
turn the trans all
use the side of the time spider walk
it's like a large frying pan and okay
and then from there literally slice okay
don't worry and a grater
okay look don't worry about chopping
this grate the ginger okay that whale
disintegrate so quickly look at that
again grate the ginger take the knife
will there be a spoon and look pull it
in there okay nice from there take the
garlic pan down make that down nice and
flat
I just carefully grate the garlic that
way it disintegrates so quickly look
that's my whole clove of garlic almost
gone that chunk look down and down
[Music]
garlic please
and the most amazing chins up but we got
color on that okay so the gas up now
that's a reading of star add a touch
more okay from there pan down make the
peppers take off the stalk and just
slice round that way we leave the seeds
in the middle okay we don't those seeds
in there and look off like that and then
from there literally just use the knife
and go up and down now I'm gonna put
some yellow pepper a little bit of red
in there like I said there's no big
difference in flavor
okay they literally taste the same so
don't worry now pepper slice I can
thinly let the knife do the work one
finger in front to behind and guide that
knife across there pepper don't go too
thin okay from there literally clean the
knife down that is called caramelized
there's nothing preventing there yellow
peppers in okay now wave that noise the
time now we're literally coming up to
six minutes to go now please stop put me
off Megan
pan down pen down peppers in I'm not
happy told to slow down for the other
right from there again such a pepper
they go in on top of the yellow okay
give that tilt it down and pull back up
tilt it down pull back
thank you go heating the pan and dust
the outside of the pan with a touch more
oil now make yeah
these are delicious little mangia - okay
group them up and just go through them
just like that
okay now Jim come on Stu green beans
crispy it's a stir fry okay but looking
good down I'm spending all those peppers
in the inside of the pan as well
okay from there hot choice the secret
here is you get the big leaf put all the
small ones inside of that okay chop that
there and roll that nice and tight see
that like what are your friends make
when they roll their cigars
[Laughter]
yes okay okay
mo I'm sorry but it's it's the
destruction of girls now slicing stalks
here we go from there stalks him first
they take down seconds and then put the
other tops give the tops in there okay
now from there okay we have got
literally three minutes to go mushrooms
in now from there a little touch of soy
in there okay you got gas on a little
touch of fish sauce optional helps you
season it okay and the last thing would
have put in there is SP onions
now look slice them nice and thick I
want to taste those fingers in there
okay keep them there for moments
[ __ ]
now from there make and down I tend to
be look at the color of that now that
site has literally caroli those peppers
yeah you're going to put this together
okay you put this together way how much
rice how much pepper and how much meat
you won in there I'm going to show the
basics now here we go now this is
optional okay get the pan nice and hot
okay you take an egg always crank up on
a flat surface
open that up okay get a little fork and
now they come down now from there
Matilda please move it up you do well
again breathing deep oil into the pan
egg in and watch that goes in whisk that
around round
I give that egg a little seasoning from
there create the salt just a light touch
and then lightly toss in with your rice
now Matua look at this building they'll
keep that heat in the pan ain't
described in our love brings in spring
onions in and put some my peppers back
in there okay and then my mix remember
the midst of the beginning we're going
time and then look mixed up now and then
all the do very quickly
yes it's some coriander I did
[Music]
come on please stop I done in ten yes I
took you over but most important there's
nothing for two three four so you have
the barriers in terms of how much
how much puppy put in there why should I
say don't wait to see what you've done
stay strong thank you not easily and we
come together cooking trust me we'll get
through this
god bless and I'll see
you